Thank You audible for sponsoring this
video thank you
it's the time of year people are running
around getting gifts for all kinds of
people but what about giving herself a
gift now is the best time to give
yourself a gift with an audible
membership and you can do it with this
special offer right now for a limited
time you get three months of audible
four to six ninety-five a month that is
over half off the normal price ooh
50% off pretty good access a beautiful
selection of audiobooks you got memoirs
you got autobiographies you got novels
you got all kinds of awesome selections
this is an audible on any device anytime
anywhere on the audible app I can hear
it it's great when you're working out at
the gym or you just shopping around at
the mall and you're listening with
audible you can enjoy easy audio book
exchanges and keep your library forever
in eternity yep give yourself the gift
of listening go to audible.com slash JK
news or text JK news to 500 500 so I
just recently downloaded this audio book
called how to strangle a man with my
bare hands
it's called civilized to death by
christopher ryan and he's an
anthropologist and i think it's really
interesting because what he's explaining
is that the way society is evolving its
further and further away from our
natural state which is why we keep
getting more depressed more sick and
every single solution that we have to a
problem is actually creating three or
four more problems and people thought I
was crazy for wanting to live in a mud
hut in nature no you're actually right
like this is the reason why and what I
like about this guy christopher ryan is
that he's actually living what he
preaches so he just lives in a van he
just travels the world like
pneumatically it's a really cool book
really interesting and I'm learning a
lot of good English from him though so
make sure you download it go check it
out all you got to do is go to
audible.com slash JK news or text JK
news to 500 500 or I'm gonna go ahead
and leave the link in the description
box below you could go ahead and click
and he'll take you straight there you
get three months inaudible for just 695
a month Thank You audible now time for a
regularly scheduled video deep deep deep
in a human and the Beast News made if I
open the door the Discovery Channel is
pitting man against bear final
competition series yep
it's called the man vs. bear its
Discovery Channel's new competition
series where humans are competing
against these three bears named Bart
honey bump that's diet and use a bear
they'll have to compete riding bicycles
juggling no so it's like for example a
game of tug-of-war the Bears are the
Bears don't have opposable thumbs how
are no good to use brute force to roll
giant logs
so here's oh wait so here's one for you
I'm a song train oh well you said that I
thought you said hug of wall and I was
like who wants to hug a bear I think
that sounds like a bad bump it's like a
big heavy man three Grizzlies that are
involved in the show the bear is treated
well yeah I know yeah they're part of
this like a sanctuary if I'm picking up
[ __ ] tires and flipping them over or
whatever and I look over to see a bear
doing it - I think I stopped everything
I'm doing and I leave we're all looking
at a hologram we must be that is nuts
yeah so they're saying that Bart is the
largest most powerful grizzly on the
mountain with no other best ideas
strength and versatility
honey bump is the only female on bear
mountain is she's the fastest fight gets
it to them huh she's the only bear on
bear nothing only female bear yeah she's
the best of the pack and boasts a level
of ferocity and predatory instinct that
tops her male counterparts so Bart and
honey bump were orphaned as Cubs and
they were discovered by an Alaska state
trooper
so they're brother and sister I don't
think so they don't mention that but
they do mention that they were rescued
and they were adopted by these two
caretakers along with tank the bear
known for his voracious appetite so who
adopted you and Joe but wait this sounds
like yeah how do you adopt a bear or
you'll excuse me only filed paperwork
because obviously they're into me like
no how does that work I don't know
you're an animal person tell me are you
dr. bear how do you adopt a bear well I
use the process well first you have to
apply they need you to look at your
record to see how well you did with
other bears that you foster but right
and then once they look at like your
record and may see a while you take care
of the Bears then you're put on a list
or like a short adoption list for a bear
so any mama bears that are like not good
like maybe they did drugs during their
pregnancy maybe they like maybe they
just like ran away yeah they like just
you know as a teenage pregnancy bear
pregnancy then you're on the list to get
the bear cub absolutely and then you
have to fill out a lot of paperwork you
have to prove you're financially stable
and that you have enough acreage for the
bear to live on bears are expensive
they're really expensive unsubscribed
from bear facts and then would you ever
like think ever like this is what it's
like to be Barrett would you want to
know like the mindset of a bear like you
attach electrodes from the bear head to
her head she said is like Ron the view
really
all right yeah would you really want to
know the mindset everybody think about
it before yeah all right let me get back
to you can yeah I expect a full report
yeah so they did tell me how tall and
how much Bart ways so he finally stands
at eight feet six inches and weighs a
thousand four hundred pounds
what the [ __ ] holy how is this even a
competition yeah yeah like I feel like
the people are done TIFF what is this
weigh them that was my question like do
you like okay fat so like get on the
scale I don't think they insult them
first I mean they're scared of the bear
okay all right they may be like oh you
Reuben is like big scales on the floor
they just walk on my floor truck did you
imagine they probably crush a regular
scale if they went on it they're like oh
we don't read you you'd need like how
many of them they only go to like 200
and it makes me feel so much better
about getting on the scale now cuz
you're not the size of a bear yeah not
even close feel like it somedays don't
we all ladies you have the bear going
first just right before you say it's
like fresh in your mind
true how light you are is there a girl
in this competition er is that all many
guys honey bum
oh no appointment oh I believe they are
mm-hmm what's preventing the bear like
when it started with a competition
starts the bear just jumping across and
eating the person that was my question
because there's nothing like that there
really must understood they wouldn't do
that to you weren't attracted to certain
people not just that but these very good
kid about you do bears have been cared
for for the past 20 years also they like
you we see that pair documentary about
that guy who was like save the photos
and then he got yeah grizzly man and
then he died by getting mauled by a bear
but he still went down defending them so
he was like I'm not supposed to be here
right now cuz so he would go to this
bear island place and then like they
were like all cool and he's like showing
everyone how cool bears are and then he
like got in a bad position where he's
like I have to live here but I'm not
supposed to be here they're gonna hurt
if they see me you die why aren't you
acting out what your wife is doing you
had a complete opportunity to improvise
that with what it in your arm and you
missed it you didn't do it right I
wasn't paying attention I haven't passed
again you're out already
thank you fine obviously you know who's
actually taking care of the bear in this
relationship actually Syd if you're
paying attention he would never have a
weapon because you don't need one around
the Bears why that was his honest
mistake I think really yeah because he
got viciously killed by bears
he never had any bear spray or nothing
he no I probably saw that coming can we
go back to the question of would want to
have a bear's mindset yeah true or no a
yogi bear yet minds that we're just
trying to steal pic-a-nic basket I would
like that yeah I want to know the angry
violent mama bear and this the badass
one in this competition know her rage
would you want to experience that for
yours yeah yeah yeah for sure who would
you take it out on maybe him should just
like stop before the question but sorry
I couldn't okay yeah yeah you're you're
right yeah yes yeah how how that's a
quick house throw that I won't say
what's in front of the house because you
told me what was in front of a house oh
you know where I would attack him oh I
would just just stand on him and then I
would just go Bart you had an
opportunity to act like a plastic coffee
guy this wasn't feeling that bear like
okay she was ahead of the curve okay
tell me more about the show oh yeah I
could not be more interested in the show
ever
Sam when does it air and when can he be
on it and you what thank you premieres
December 4th okay so it will happen
well the bears hibernate I think Oh max
Lana can release now because they've
already oh yeah yeah yeah where would
you hide Nate if you were a bear
Chris the dream sounds good
well gosh I know but like it's not like
a dark Krispy Kreme and like I don't
know some cave somewhere I could surely
need to worry about where you go the bet
what do you go to bathroom when you're
hibernating you don't everything just
shuts down could you imagine if they got
a colonic what would come out a lotta
[ __ ] oh my god did you do bare colonics
in the show I'd be pretty possible [ __ ]
up their ass not even hey you should
open a bear salon I don't know why I do
you have a lot of hair - for their mind
games that they play against the Bears
can you bear it
mmm that would have been a way better
title yeah man vs. bear but they're
saying that this whole thing so that's
because there's man vs. wild and Bear
Grylls and like those two are already
confusing and now you're gonna give me
man vs. bear I'm thinking it's man vs.
wild vs. bear girls pretty close
trademark that what Tennant were those
shows on Oh an old plant or some [ __ ]
yeah pine IG order stuff travel yeah is
on discovery
oh no oh maybe discover I don't know
have you guys ever been camping and been
like sincerely like worried that the
bear was gonna attack on a bear but a
pack of coyotes were swirling around our
tent one time and it was Gary that's
really scary it was it was the middle of
the night and so I was in a dream and in
so in my head it was like a bunch of
dachshund wiener dogs yeah cuz they're
like and it was like all the dachshunds
like I thought they were like wiener
dogs around I don't know why my brain
like felt that way and I was like I want
all of them it was like a bag my eggs
boycott wake up she's gonna wish I'm
like I just want to adopt them um we
just seen as quiet as possible and until
they went away if they're like really
aggressively like scary and they were
like howling and like they're near your
tent they were all like we could hear
them right outside the tent like like it
was he's crazy
coyote I thought it was a really like
messed up dog and it sound like
you're rendering spongebob with the
slinky I can't even describe that
episode but they made similar sound they
said can I ask you a question
fine do you think they should give
coyotes a Bluetooth headset so they can
communicate with each other better
I don't even know why they haven't done
that yet Bart why don't you get on that
Bart I was just asking
Bart act it out I don't even know what
my role is any the questions she has in
her brain out stop looking at him I'm so
sorry I didn't saw that yeah I'm sorry
I'm sorry
so my thing is I don't know why they
don't have that I don't know why they
don't have IV hangovers for them because
you know it sorry you know bears drink a
lot you know it's like why do you think
they get to over a thousand pounds it's
not just food excellent fishers great
fishers but they're kind of alcoholics
so watch out for bear I think bluetooth
would help a lot of people if they had
at you I think Bluetooth [ __ ] with
people's brains Buster's minor maybe
bears need that because they're so drunk
all the time maybe it levels the Mount
drunk on what honey hello hello hello I
haven't read a bear welcome back how
nice does that sound that all you get to
do is eat and like attack things and
then have honey and then like look cute
[Music]
you
[Music]